je vais partir d'ici j'ai souvent
redouté cette journée soit avisé méfie
toi tout ce qu'il te faudra et et femmes
en toi nous avons une mission monsieur
howard n'es tu pas le septième fils d'un
septième fils
un ordre de proches et valier déterminé
à combattre les forces de l'obscur il
est écrit que vous êtes des milliers ils
sont tous morts
alors il ne reste plus que vous m
grégory apprenez moi tu vis dans un
monde nouveau où les légendes et les
colimaçons
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
le diable est à nos portes
les signes du mal sont omniprésents
votre reine est de retour
ans au monde un avant goût de ce qui
l'attend
si tu vois une sorcière tu là
nous ne sommes pas tout aussi pernicieux
sens je ne suis pas comme vous je suis
incapable
un jouanno